hausse des prix à qui ça profite les
agriculteurs et éleveurs peuvent-ils s'y
retrouver la promotion de la viande
végétale par Bruno Le Maire la
sécheresse dans quelques régions de
France les questions d'empruntoeuvre
dans le secteur agricole nous allons en
parler puis la stigmatisation si des
ruraux par l'écologie Camille Étienne
qu'on a entendu la semaine dernière on
l'a évoqué ce matin voici quelques-unes
des questions que nous allons évoquer
avant tout ces sujets Marc venus si vous
le voulez bien quelques mots aussi sur
la suite de la réforme des retraites
parce que le groupe liotte que vous
connaissez veut l'abroger lors d'un vote
8 juin vous êtes ancien ministre des
Relations avec le Parlement que doit
faire la majorité laisser ce vote se
dérouler ou l'empêcher mais il faut
qu'il y a un débat au Parlement mais il
appartient pas à personne ni
ni au gouvernement ni au groupe liote ni
à personne de déterminer ce que seront
le choix et les desiderata des
parlementaires je trouve assez original
l'idée que parce que ça serait un texte
du groupe il serait intouchable on
pourrait pas y avoir d'amendement on
pourrait même pas discuter de sa
constitutionnalité au regard de
l'article 40 ce qui s'est appliqué dans
tous les textes ou surtout beaucoup des
textes sauf quand le gouvernement
acceptait de lever le gage il faut que
tout le monde accepte le débat et donc
se faire faire un grief de de refus de
débat par ce groupe et les présidents de
ces groupes de ce groupe il y a quelque
chose d'assez original qui a déposé 20
000 amendements quand le texte a été
présenté par la première Mini sur le
texte retraite c'est pas nous hein c'est
des gens de l'opposition y compris des
gens du groupe lyaute et désormais on se
poserait la question soit de poser des
amendements non pas par milliers mais
par dizaines ou centaines on vient dire
vous faites obstacle à la démocratie et
puis deux il faut qu'on essaie de
remettre les idées en place on peut pas
être dans un pays on peut avoir des
querelles sur le sur les textes sur les
objectifs sur tout ce qu'on veut on peut
pas être dans un pays qui s'affranchit
allègrement pas après pas de toutes les
règles de droit ce texte
s'il était voté au bout il serait jugé
un
constitutionnels
40 non non c'est pas parce que c'est
voté que ça n'est pas un constitutionnel
je vous rappelle d'ailleurs qu'il y a un
conseil constitutionnel pour un juger
donc c'est pas parce que c'est voté que
c'est constitutionnel donc ça serait
bien je dis ça très pacifiquement mais
ça serait bien que quand on produit des
textes on se on s'assure qu'il soit bien
constitutionnel mais
si on est dans une dans un moment où il
faut s'affranchir de toute règle de
droit constitutionnel moi je pour ma
part je le regrette et c'est pas faire
un jour à la démocratie que dire que ça
serait mieux de respecter la
Constitution bon nous verrons ce qui se
passe après voilà les gros
parlementaires de la majorité ceux de
l'opposition se saisiront la question
mais la vraie question au bout pardon
c'est pas seulement la
constitutionnalité c'est pas seulement
est-ce qu'on a le droit encore de faire
des abonnements dans ce pays même quand
on est dans la majorité fut-elle
relative la seule question c'est comment
finance-t-il le système des retraites et
la vérité ils n'ont pas de réponse à ça
la seule élément certains
ont des éléments de réponse c'est à dire
qu'ils n'ont pas de réponse à la vérité
le seul sujet qui vaille pour le pays
quand en Espagne quand au Portugal quand
dans tous les pays d'Europe la tendance
est à l'allongement et c'est pas par
plaisir que je dis ça c'est c'est
plaisant pour personne cette affaire là
la seule question c'est est-ce qu'on est
capable d'équilibrer système de retraite
si on n'est pas capable de répondre à
cette question là on fait pas œuvre de
démocratie parce qu'en fait on mange aux
citoyens français et moi je pense qu'en
démocratie la pire des choses c'est de
mentir et donc on n'a pas un système de
retraite qui est équilibré on a un
système de retraite qui va encore se
déséquilibrer et donc la seule question
qui vaille c'est comment on fait en
sorte
le président de la République qui a il y
a 3 ans en arrière avait dit qu'il y
avait pas besoin d'y toucher quoi mais
bon les choses ont changé quoi
visiblement parce que dans le temps
laissez-moi répondre bien sûr oui je
vous rappelle que avant la crise covid
il y avait un texte où il y avait des
mesures paramétriques et il y avait des
mesures de systèmes et donc il y avait
des mesures d'équilibre simplement à la
vérité il y a trois ou quatre ans le
corps le Conseil d'orientation des
retraites nous avait expliqué qu'il y
avait pas de problème puis après nous
expliquer qu'il y avait un problème puis
après nous expliquer qu'il y avait pas
de problème la vérité c'est qu'il faut
se faire soi-même sa religion sur ces
sujets là et que manifestement nous ne
faisons pas exception à la règle
mondiale c'est dans un système
démographique tel qu'il est le système
les retraites n'est plus équilibré oui
alors venons-en maintenant un secteur
qui vous concerne aussi directement
puisque vous êtes ministre de
l'Agriculture de la souveraineté
alimentaire c'est l'inflation le pouvoir
le pouvoir d'achat la hausse des prix
notamment et bien sûr dans l'alimentaire
alors qu'on comprenne bien là il y a de
nouvelles commerciaux négociations
commerciales qui doivent être engagés là
c'est ça la porte a été ouverte avec
l'acceptation d'un certain nombre de
grands groupes alimentaires qui puisse y
avoir des renégociations commerciales
c'est la règle du commerce qui puisse
avoir des relations je rappelle que dans
les contrats tels qu'ils sont signés il
y a des clauses de revoyure donc il est
bien que la grande distribution et les
grands groupes puissent rediscuter des
des clauses des contrats et de dire
est-ce que là il y a pas une baisse qui
peut se produire parce que il y a un
certain nombre de facteurs qui
produisent rappelons aussi que
l'inflation c'est un sujet compliqué
pardon de le dire comme ça c'est-à-dire
que avant que l'inflation arrive et
c'est à dire c'est ce qu'on voit il y a
parfois un délai de latence qui a
plusieurs semaines voire plusieurs mois
quand vous commandez quand les pâtes que
vous avez aujourd'hui sur les étals des
rayons des supermarchés c'est des pâtes
qui sont produites avec du blé qui a été
récolté en 2022 sur des prix de 2022
avec des prix d'engrais de 2022 et donc
regarder les prix de 2023 pour dire il
faut baisser c'est un peu faire une
heure parce que la pâte que vous avez
sous les yeux elle n'est pas le produit
des prix de 2023 les produits des prix
de 2022 vous avez par ailleurs parfois
des emballages les emballages quand vous
produisez un produit ils sont achetés 3
4 6 8 mois avant et donc il y a une
forme d'inertie à la montée et il y a
une forme d'inertie à la descente et
donc il y a une logique à ce que ça soit
un peu décalé dans le temps simplement
l'objectif que nous avons c'est de faire
en sorte que à l'été et une forme de
stabilisation avant qu'une décrue
s'opère s'il y avait pas d'accident
supplémentaire d'un point de vue
géopolitique bon et du côté des
agriculteurs alors est-ce que eux
peuvent s'y retrouver en fait
aujourd'hui les agriculteurs et les
éleveurs français la question centrale
c'est il faut pas opposer la question du
prix et la question du pouvoir d'achat
ou la question des éleveurs parce que ou
des éleveurs ou des agriculteurs parce
que les éleveurs aussi bien sûr les
agriculteurs ont eu des coups de revient
beaucoup plus importants exactement ce
que je viens de défendre devant vous
c'est on a besoin de tenir à la fois une
inflation ou si maîtrise que possible il
y a eu des mesures qui ont été prises
par le gouvernement
pendant 10 ans personne ne sait jamais
inquiété pendant 10 ans d'une déflation
d'une déflation sur les produits
agricoles ça veut dire que tous les ans
les agriculteurs et les industries
agroalimentaires d'ailleurs au passage
perdaient de la valeur et perdez du
revenu personne c'est inquiété de ça ça
c'était pour ça par certains grands
distributeurs et ça on a perdu quoi on a
perdu de la valeur et à la vérité on a
perdu de la souveraineté alimentaire
donc il faut être vigilant sur cette
question des prix et de ne pas être des
Magog il y a une question qui est posée
à nous tous pour essayer de maintenir au
mieux en particulier pour les Français
qui sont avec le moindre revenu parce
que ça c'est une exigence mais en même
temps dire le meilleur prix c'est le
plus bas prix c'est à mon avis
collectivement une erreur est-ce que la
filière du bio pourra se remettre la
dune crise actuelle qui est qui la
frappe l'objectif du de plan qu'on a
annoncé qui est un plan avec aide
d'urgence et une aide à la pour
structurer la demande c'est environ 200
millions d'euros 60 millions d'aide de
crise d'urgence et puis 120 + 10
millions qui avait déjà été annoncé plus
de 120 sur comment booste la commande
publique la commande publique c'est un
formidable levier donc c'est la première
grande crise du bio c'est une crise pour
moi qui est une crise de croissance
avant on disait il y a pas assez
d'offres maintenant on dit il y a pas
assez de demandes donc il faut qu'on
pousse la demande et puis qu'on aide les
agriculteurs bio à passer ce cap parce
que c'est un câble difficile et la
conversion l'agriculture bio est un est
un cours cette c'est souvent très
compliqué techniquement et donc faut
plutôt les encourager
le ministre de l'Agriculture et de la
souveraineté alimentaire que vous êtes
et forcément aussi concerné par
l'ensemble des plans d'actions qui sont
présentés en début de semaine contre les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
demain la sécheresse qu'elles sont pour
vous les priorités les priorités
l'agriculture associe de particulier qui
était à la fois comme toutes les
activités économiques et maîtrise de de
CO2 et par ailleurs elle est la seule
activité qui peut stocker du CO2 parce
que les prairies ça stocke du CO2 parce
que produire de la biomasse ça stocke du
CO2 donc on est et que par ailleurs on
va demander à la lecture de produire
plus de biomasse pour d'autres usages
pour le effectivement pour l'énergie et
donc il faut qu'on arrive à trouver un
point d'équilibre et ça sera l'objet des
débats que nous aurons y compris cet
après-midi autour de la première
ministre c'est comme on arrive à trouver
un point d'écrit pour produire de la
biomasse il faut il faut des
fertilisants qui soient des carbonés il
faut pour donner un seul exemple et puis
il faut un peu d'eau et donc comme on
arrive à trouver un équilibre entre ces
deux tensions on sait que on a besoin de
faire des efforts sur le passé des
fertilisants minéraux fertilisant
organique les uns étant produit avec de
l'énergie fossile les autres et ton
produit sans énergie fossile on sait
qu'on a une trajectoire à trouver sur
l'élevage sans stigmatiser l'élevage
pour essayer de réduire l'empreinte
carbone aussi et c'est ce chemin là
qu'il faut qu'on essaie de trouver bon
ça a l'air d'être difficile Bruno Le
Maire lui il s'est attiré les des
agriculteurs ce week-end en faisant la
promotion de la viande végétale les
bouchers également qui l'ont accusé
d'être le fossoyeur de la filière viande
vous comprenez leur inquiétude moi je
comprends tout à fait leur inquiétude
alors à vrai dire j'ai vu que Bruno Le
Maire avait
je sais pas si c'est rectifié mais avait
précisé ce qui avait été sa pensée j'ai
vu dans une autre émission il avait fait
l'éloge e de la côte de bâche je pense
qu'il faut qu'on essaye et c'est pas le
sujet de Bruno Le Maire là pour le coup
collectivement
de poser ces questions là sans opposer
les modèles et sans opposer on a le
droit de manger des végétaux et on a le
droit de manger de la viande sans
stigmatiser les uns et les autres et si
on pouvait pas séparer le monde entre
vegetariens et non végétariens ça serait
bien et ça serait bien pour tout le
monde la trajectoire globale on sait
qu'il y a plutôt une légère décrue de la
consommation de viande assumons-le comme
tel l'important c'est passé à
l'important c'est qu'il y a des éleveurs
sur le territoire
l'important c'est qu'il soit rémunéré et
la troisième chose importante et ça
revient au début de votre question c'est
qu'il soit pas stigmatisé parce que moi
j'ai besoin d'éleveur pour nous nourrir
j'ai besoin d'éleveur pour leur fonction
de biodiversité de carte on peut pas à
la fois dire je veux maintenir les je
veux maintenir les prairies je veux
maintenir des paysages je veux lutter
contre les incendies et passer son temps
à dézinguer ou à démolir le métier
d'éleveur qui est un métier en plus où
on est très peu rémunéré et donc il faut
qu'on sorte de cette spirale infernale
qui vise à stigmatiser dans ce pays
Étienne par exemple poussent le bouchon
un peu loin quand elle stigmatisait de
l'ensemble en fait du grande rurale
d'ailleurs elle pousse je sais pas
rassemblement national alors que moi je
vais pas on va pas se laisser faire
donner la leçon moi je suis un élu du
monde rural je veux pas me faire donner
la leçon par des gens moi ça fait 15 ans
que au lieu d'aller devant des micros
j'essaie de faire des choses sur le bois
énergie sur la préservation d'un certain
nombre d'espèces dans mon territoire
donc je vais pas me laisser divertir
parce que ça relève de ce registre là
par des gens qui viennent à longueur de
tribune donner des leçons aux autres je
ne connais pas une transition qui soit
faisable si vous passez votre temps à
dire celui-ci il est comme ça celui-là
il est comme ça et celui-là je le
stigmatise la stigmatisation c'est la
meilleure façon de pas avancer et se
faire donner des sons de politique de
vie de culture
de manière de produire par des gens qui
n'y vivent pas ne voient pas les
contraintes et ne veulent pas les
accepter y compris pour dire faut qu'on
fasse des transitions vous m'entendez
pas dire qu'il faut pas faire des
transitions mais il y a une manière de
dire les choses qui est aussi importante
que de faire les choses elles-mêmes Marc
fenou est-ce que l'agriculture française
est menacée est-ce que elle peut
disparaître quasiment dans les années
qui viennent moi je passe pas mais non
plus
avec une diminution annoncée de sortir
de la colopsologie Générale qu'est-ce
que quels sont les menaces pour la
culture la principale menace pour moi
c'est le sujet le sujet du dérèglement
climatique parce que ça vient mettre en
tension un système et ça va venir
perturber nos modes d'organisation
agricole et puis deux c'est de faire en
sorte que la compétitivité de la fin de
France mais emploi tous les jours comme
vous le savez elle soit restaurée parce
que ça ça peut être une menace pour le
maintien de l'agriculture interne après
nous avons des agriculteurs qui sont
très bien formés qui sont très
techniquement très au point et puis je
crois un attachement des français de
l'Agriculture donc il faudra faire
preuve chaque jour pour les accompagner
dans ces transitions et mon état à leur
côté au niveau de l'État est-ce qu'il y
a une inquiétude aussi au niveau de la
sécheresse là il y a eu des pluies
depuis trois semaines qui sont tombés
certaines régions ont pu regonfler leur
nappe phréatique mais pas toutes mais je
peux vous dire deux choses il faut qu'on
essaie de regarder ces questions de
sécheresse non pas à 3 mois mais à 30
ans parce que on va pas passer moi je ne
suis pas météorologue je vais pas passer
mon temps à commenter il a plus 20
minutes il a pas plus 20 mm
trois quarts du pays il y a pas de
situation sécheresse de surface
puisqu'il a plus bon alors les nappes
sont basses mais comme il a plus il y a
pas besoin d'irriguer donc il y a pas de
date à date il y a pas d'inquiétude
majeur en particulier sur les céréales
qu'on récolte au mois de juin début
juillet ce qu'on appelle les céréales à
la paille donc c'est plutôt un bon cap
qui est passé après on a dans le sud
cette année un phénomène de sécheresse
je vous rappelle qu'à 300 km de là en
Italie il est tombé 250 mm d'eau donc
soyons prudent un commentaire à court
terme en revanche on sait qu'il y a des
systèmes agricoles qui sont plus soumis
à stress hydrique que d'autres en
particulier dans ces raisons du Sud et
que globalement il faut qu'on raisonne
un système agricole avec des des aléas
climatiques beaucoup trop d'eau pas
assez d'eau aujourd'hui alors je vous
parle il y a des régions dans les
Hauts-de-France en particulier on ne
peut pas planter les pommes de terre
parce qu'il y a trop d'eau donc
sur cette année l'inquiétude principale
elle est autour du bassin méditerranéen
si les choses ont resté là en espérant
que on n'est pas un gros épisode de
chaleur ou de sécheresse pour l'instant
a vu de météorologues à un mois
manifestement pas de gros épisodes de
chaleur parce que la canicule sur plus
pas d'eau ça fait beaucoup donc ça peut
se retourner mais pour ce qui est du
printemps le rattrapage a commencé à se
faire de février qui n'avait pas été du
tout humide sur Mars et Avril et on
verra maintenant on verra mais après la
question je répète c'est pas de regarder
la météo de l'été 2023 la question de
c'est de faire en sorte que nous nous
préparions à des épisodes de dérèglement
climatique qui vont lourdement impacter
l'agriculture Marc féno il y a quelques
jours ce micro marine tondeuillier
s'inquiétait de la disparition des
oiseaux avec une étude qui est apparue
récemment elle disait qu'elle pensait
aux oiseaux la nuit vous y pensez vous
aussi ou pas je pense pas qu'aux oiseaux
je pense à l'ensemble de la biodiversité
et je pense aussi à la biodiversité
humaine donc je pense aussi à ceux qui
sont sur le territoire et je pense à la
nécessité que nous avons de restaurer la
biodiversité la question des oiseaux
c'est la question de la manière dont
s'alimente les oiseaux la question des
oiseaux c'est la question de la
restauration des haies j'ai lancé les
travaux pour qu'on ait un plan et des
cet été la question c'est pas de
dénoncer au micro la question c'est
d'essayer de faire je dis pas que ce que
j'essaie de faire est parfait mais au
moins moi j'essaye et donc il faut qu'on
essaie de trouver des voies et moyens
sur la biodiversité pour faire en sorte
que nous retrouvions des populations
d'oiseaux qui soient satisfaits je pense
que ça participe de la richesse d'un
territoire que d'avoir aussi une
biodiversité qui soit riche dernière
question marcenot sur les céréales c'est
vrai que l'Ukraine peut produire de
nouveau et elle est exonérée de
certaines taxes ça peut déséquilibrer
les marchés ça ou pas ça n'a pas
déséquilibrer les marchés au niveau
français c'est un peu déséquilibré les
marchés reconnaissant l'eau frontières
polonaises et roumaine d'où des mesures
de protection et d'où des mesures d'aide
qu'il faut toujours penser comme des
mesures à la fois de solidarité à
l'Ukraine parce que on doit cette
solidarité à l'Ukraine et deuxièmement
comme des mesures au niveau européen
personne ne peut prendre des mesures
unilatérales donc j'ai beaucoup plaidé
pour qu'on fasse
en sorte d'avoir des mesures qui soient
de niveau européen et pas y par pays
sinon on ferait des fois l'esprit
européen merci merci